I could think is why do you need women
in society because women again do make
the world go WR but do you think a man
would get out of bed and work and
actually try to achieve good things if
it weren't for trying to gain a woman's
attention a man could sleep on a bench
and be happy and sleep outside they earn
money do everything they do to impress
women so so I was thinking about this
too okay I was like let me think what
would Society look like if women
disappeared outside of I know we give
them the kids but let's take the kids
out of this the family okay and I was
thinking I'm like would men still
explore I think yes would men still
build things I think yes I think there's
an innate nature of men that want to
build things explore the world and they
did do this on a TV show